well throughout this campaign i've said
that the new prime minister's sole
economic priority must be to bear down
ruthlessly on inflation and support
people with their bills now i'm simply
not going to promise anything that
undermines my ability to deliver on that
and i get that alternative plans of
permanent tax cuts funded by borrowing
may sound attractive at first but if
they risk stoking inflation and actually
do nothing to help poorer people and
pensioners then they actually are going
to be bad for everyone ultimately
governing is about choosing and i think
people know that if something sounds too
good to be true it probably is
we know the energy price cap is due to
go up on friday labor and many energy
bosses are calling for it to be frozen
people are frankly terrified about how
they're going to afford to live over
this winter you don't support that
freeze i understand but what concrete
measures do you have in mind to actually
help people with this what are you going
to do about the price of energy well as
chancellor i introduced a wimpful tax on
the energy companies because i believe
that is the fair and right thing to do
in these circumstances and i announced
support for people this autumn winter
but this situation has got worse since
then so as prime minister i would go
further i'd cut vat on energy bills to
provide some help to everyone but i want
to provide direct financial assistance
to two other groups of people those on
the lowest incomes and pensioners
because those people will need extra
help this autumn winter and i know
things are difficult and i want them to
be reassured that with me as prime
minister they will get the help that
they need people are trying to budget
now though as you say the situation has
changed a lot can you give us any more
specific details about the kind of
support you would offer to the most
vulnerable
well i've set out a clear framework for
how to provide that support i would cut
vat off energy bills to coincide with
the increase in the price cap that's
something we can do very quickly but
beyond that for two groups of people for
pensioners and for those on the lowest
incomes i will make sure that they get
direct extra financial support over the
autumn and winter to help them with
those bills because i know this is the
number one concern people have
my approach is the right one it provides
direct help to the most vulnerable in
our society and doesn't do things that
risk making the situation worse and
actually permanent tax cuts funded by
borrowing may sound attractive but if
they stoke inflation and do nothing to
help these groups of people who i know
need help then actually no one benefits
from that and and that's why i think my
plan is the right one my approach is the
right one and as prime minister i can
deliver that for the british people
on monday nearly 1300 migrants arrived
across the channel seems that they're a
threat of being deported to rwanda isn't
working what's your response to that and
what needs to be done about it well
earlier in this campaign i talked about
some of the emergencies facing our
country and illegal migration is one of
the ones that i listed that i would
tackle as a priority as prime minister
because i think it's wrong and i came
here or my family came here because our
country has a proud history of welcoming
migrants but that has to be done legally
has to be done fairly and when people
are exploiting the system that's wrong
and it must be stopped i've set out a
detailed plan for how to get to grips
with it it involves removing the
european definition of asylum moving to
a different international definition
that will help us remove people i will
do whatever it takes to make the rwanda
plan work because we must have control
of our borders and as prime minister
that's what i will deliver
latest forecasts suggesting inflation
could reach 18 next year you previously
said that we can take measures to
control inflation you've talked about
how liz trust is going to add to
inflation but what concrete measures can
you tell us about that you would bring
in to actually curb inflation
well i think we need to let the bank of
england get on with its job with
interest rates and i'm worried quite
frankly by reports from others that they
want to curb the independence of the
bank of england i think that would be a
mistake and i think it would spook
international investors into the united
kingdom it would be bad for all of us
secondly i want to make sure that we
increase the supply of things if you
want to bring the price down of them
that means moving people off welfare and
into work to ease some of the pressures
in our labor market it means increasing
the supply of homegrown energy and food
to reduce inflationary pressures there
and embarking on a big program of energy
efficiency to help people insulate their
homes which reduces their bills and
helps us get to net zero and increases
our energy security but last but not
least we can't put fuel on the fire and
that's why i'm worried about plans that
would pump tens of billions of pounds of
borrowed money into an economy at a time
when inflation and interest rates are
already rising i think that's a big
gamble i don't want to put fuel on the
fire i don't think that's the right
approach i think it's risky and it's not
something i will do as prime minister
did you do enough to control inflation
when you were a child
well of course when i was chancellor i
was also dealing with a pandemic and
people will remember it's probably the
first time that they got to know who i
was at the beginning of the pandemic and
i'm proud of my record because we were
forecast to have unemployment spiraling
into the millions and because of the
interventions that i put in place i
managed to safeguard our economy through
the biggest shock it had experienced in
300 years and actually we're in more
resilient shape now as a result of the
actions i took but now
we do have to make sure that we bring
inflation down which is my priority and
we support the most vulnerable with the
cost of living this autumn and winter
that's my plan and if i'm elected as
prime minister that's what i'll deliver
and comment just like you one very final
question just for the pool i mean people
are very worried about what they're
going to do this winter we've talked
about the energy price cap inflation and
so on energy chiefs saying this race is
going on too long we need a prime
minister in place now who can take
decisions this country needs should you
not be standing aside for the good of
the country
i'm going out and about across the
country talking to our members about my
plan because i believe it's the right
plan for our country and it's a
resonating message with people
everywhere i go i'm doing multiple
events as you can see here today and i
know that i can act very quickly if i'm
uh selected as prime minister people saw
that in the pandemic i had to move very
fast to help get our country through
some very difficult times i will do that
again if i'm prime minister people have
seen my record they know that i've got
the experience they know i've got the
ability to help get the country through
difficult times and at the moment i'm
focused relentlessly on making sure that
my plan is the one that carries the most
weight in the country thank you very
much indeed thank you appreciate your
time